we're told that the sum of three
consecutive odd integers is 231.
what is the largest integer so let's
let's think about this a little bit
let's say that x is the smallest integer
x is equal to the smallest
the smallest odd
of these three it's not the smallest odd
integer of all integers is the smallest
odd of these three the smallest odd
integer so what's the next one going to
be well if i have one odd integer what's
going to be the next odd integer let's
think about this if x was three what's
the next odd integer it's five and then
what's the next one after that it's
seven and the next one after that it's
nine so every time we add two so if the
smallest one is x the next smallest odd
integer is x plus 2
is equal to the next
the next smallest
odd integer
ah i'll write integer here
odd integer and then what will be the
next one we're going to add 2 to this
one right so it's going to be x plus 4.
think about it if the smallest is 3 then
we have x plus 2 which is 5 and then you
have x plus 4 which is 7. so this will
be the largest
largest of the consecutive odd integer
odd integer in this group and they tell
us that the sum of these consecutive odd
integers is 231 what is the largest
integer so if i take x x plus 2 and x
plus 4 and i sum them they should be
equal to 231 so let's do that
so we have x
plus
x plus 2
x plus 4 and this is this needs to be
equal to 231. and when they ask us
what's the largest one we're going to
have to tell them what x plus 4 is equal
to so let's just solve this equation so
let's add our x terms we have 1x 2x 3xs
so we get three x
plus
and then what are our constants we have
a two and we have a four so three x plus
six
is equal to
is equal to two hundred and thirty one
now let's get rid of the 6 from the left
hand side of the equation the best way
to do that is to subtract 6 from both
sides so let's subtract 6 from both
sides the left-hand side we're just left
with a 3x
just left for the 3x the 6s cancel out
the right hand side
minus 6 is 225
we get 3x is equal to 225 to isolate the
x let's just divide both sides by three
divide both sides by three the left-hand
side the threes cancel out that was the
whole point behind dividing by three we
get just an x
we get just an x is being equal to and
225 divided by three let me do it over
here so 3
goes into 225
it goes into 22
seven times 7 times 3 is
22 minus 21 is one bring down the five
three goes into 15 five times five times
three is fifteen subtract no remainder
so 225 divided by three
is
so the smallest
the smallest of the odd integers is 75
so that this one is 75 what's x plus 2
going to be equal to well that's going
to be
2 more 77
and what's x plus 4 going to be equal to
well that's the largest of them x is 75
plus 4 is going to be 79
79 and notice we have three odd integers
they're consecutive they're the you know
they're the odd integers that come
directly after each other and let's
verify that when we add them up we get
231.
so if we get 75
plus let me just write like this 75 plus
77 plus 79 i want to add them all up
5 plus 7 is 12 12 plus 9 is 21
carry the 2
2 plus 7 is 9 9 plus 7 is 16 16 plus 7
is 23.
so there you have it the three
consecutive odd integers when you add
them up you got 231
they're consecutive and odd they ask
what's the largest the largest is 79.